the scissors ass at idle the Clippers
are silent and people have been forced
into DIY from Bailey for many it's been
one of the few things to smile about in
lockdown
I've also sat in the chair with my wife
brandishing the Clippers the front it's
certainly easier than the back you don't
look too closely it's a pretty good job
but there was a much more important
issue here and that is that this entire
industry of people who cut hair
professionally still don't have any idea
when they'll be able to reopen there are
customers all over North Manchester
phoning Johanna asking when she's
opening we can get ourselves ready she's
already got some of the protective gear
and wants to do the right things but
knows that others I passed the summer
where the guy is hoping they shut this a
little bit and somebody waiting outside
I said to that guy in the car I said you
are the people that are not making this
thing go away and he said well yeah I
told her bye-bye and he wouldn't I said
boy you are sitting there you're going
to have your hair cut and that is wrong
you know I want to open I miss my work
I've been home for too long and I'm not
making any money and obviously just like
anybody else we all need their money to
survive if you really can't wait you can
also book a stylist to sit with you to
talk you through it online you don't
flick don't stop just straight up go for
it you can switch them on and 15 pounds
ago lock down haircuts is a startup
business that's paying wages and
donating profits to the NHS
dan your hair doesn't look very good as
mine doesn't again today is the you know
if your hair doesn't look good you don't
feel good and I think people want to
feel good again like so many other
businesses it will come back but it
won't be the same for quite some time
Tom Parmenter Sky News